hors des sentiers battus parfois
jusqu'au sang je me suis battu par pas
je te met au parfum sur terre battue ils
et elles sont arrivées un beau matin par
dizaines par centaines en trottinette
éclectique sourire automatique
ils ont gentrifié mon quartier huppé
risée boboïsée et lyophilisée les
derniers haricots j'ai pris cher j'ai dû
partir ici dans le loir-et-cher
provisoirement pendant cette crise
sanitaire planétaire eux ils sont
arrivés en train de l'est par bavard
dans les bars car lors de quarts schéma
moi je suis plutôt du genre nestor qui
restaure le store du restaurant pour
l'instant je suis là ce team cher je
suis à chercher noise 41 milles 180 dans
le loir et cher
[Musique]
mais del sol mais nullement pensons
oh
[Musique]
bah
le sol n'est ni soy betty boop henchoz
seul bémol mais dimension
[Musique]
celle ci quand c'est nous les fentes ans
du plus beau des poulbots le bon les
arts tard le soir
bosch aux radars ramène ton hectares en
jetons sonar tarifs data remballe de
balle avec un style poétique à la vega
musicale hier qui arrive à des castings
en palliant ici union de fait en express
et un plein de tendresse y est ça il ya
des lois c'est ça avec un style
tentaculaire maculaire plein d'eau des
cabinets des films assez pour passer des
mois c'est très long mais encore une
fois on speed c'est le pavillon non une
fois ici lucide j'ai rencontré notre vie
c'est une belle ville montent en tipi je
n'abandonne mappy par l'état pas rater
des ventes qui comprend séance écran en
poussant parfois mais sans offenser
c'est pour dépasser l'actualité ces
cours des mois c'est ce que tu crois
c'est dans ta tête et c'est progresser
nous pourquoi du comment maintenant dans
cet instant un instant car je vous
donnais d'or et moi je ne cherche pas
mais c'est tim chez hb je suivais
recherche noir ça arrive et ça rime
heures comme la mavo même donc et la
rochette en figures libres
un exercice de style
nous les tigres
nous les enfants
m
[Musique]